elle alors la délinquance est elle en
germe dès la petite enfance cette idée
elle est en germe depuis plusieurs
années maintenant des structures
spécialisées s'emploie à détecter
d'éventuels signes avant coureurs une
pratique qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
le reportage d'emmanuel lagarde et
christelle jorion l'accueil soit l'âge
des premiers pas vers la socialisation
une étape clé qui fait dire un certain
qu'on peut repérer des trois ans les
enfants en souffrance se courront se
marginaliser un jour un enfant qui mord
à une fois bien entendu pas de temps en
temps mais régulièrement dès qu'il est
contrarié il casse him or il tape il
faut l'aider à plus on agira tôt plus on
a de chances en effet qu'il ne
s'installe pas dans ce comportement
le but est de les aider est d'aider leur
famille alors tout sera dans la façon de
le présenter évidemment il faut qu'on
fasse un effort pour comprendre aux
familles qu'on va les aider
la détection précoce des troubles du
comportement
l'idée avait fait bondir nombre de
spécialistes de l'enfance
selon eux on a tendance à confondre
agressivité et prédisposition à la
délinquance en rose qui va dessiner un
bonhomme qui fait plein de bêtises
pourtant les repérages existe déjà ce
petit garçon de 5 ans par ren agressif a
besoin de venir régulièrement ici chez
la psychologue mais elle craint que la
détection systématique nous stigmatisent
les enfant c'est ça qui est dangereux
c'est qu'en fait on va déjà les mettre
dans la case ils vont être fichés ils
vont être pointé et l'environnement
parce qu'on porte et comment va se
comporter en fonction de ce qu'on lui
dit donc s'il est considéré comme enfant
avec grand trouble du comportement
possibilité probable délinquants c'est
terminé c'est moi en face et des enfants
qu'ils n'auront plus une vie normale
parce que simplement le comp
l'environnement se comportera de cette
façon là un écueil à éviter en gardant à
l'esprit qu'une fois l'adolescence venu
il est souvent trop tard pour changer
les comportements